-It is so great to see you.
You look fantastic.
-Thank you.
-"SNL" is back.
This is my favorite time
of year.
The first "Saturday Night Live"
this Saturday.
-Yeah. We're back.
-Are you ready?
Are you excited?
-I am ready.
I'm very excited.
Miles is amazing.
-He is good, right?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's going to be fun.
I -- I want to --
I told you backstage already
some of my favorite bits
that you do.
But doing your impression
of Anna Delvey on the show.
-[as Delvey] Very V.I.P.
-[as Delvey] Yeah, very V.I.P.
Very exclusive.
-Now, did you start
doing it on the show?
Like -- Just, like, on "SNL"?
-On "SNL"?
-No. I've been obsessed with
that woman for five years.
-Yeah.
-There was a Cut article
that came out, and this was
pre-me being on "SNL,"
so I would make videos
on the Gram,
you know, front-facing.
-Yeah, of course.
-And I got a wig and read the
article and then went to...
[as Delvey] 11 Howard,
where she did her crimes
by not paying for the hotel.
[Normal voice] And I was like --
There's video --
I, like, have sunglasses and
I got kicked out of the hotel.
-In real life?
-In real life.
And then I went into banks
trying to make content.
You know, like, "Run it again!"
And...
-You were doing that?
-It was so cool.
Yeah, 100%.
So cool to do it on the show.
-But then this is fun.
So, you do it on the show,
and then she reached out to you
about the impression?
-Yes. She -- Well, yes.
First, she invited me to her...
[as Delvey] Anna Delvey
Foundation exclusive.
Literally, it was, like,
very V.I.P., exclusive art show.
-Very V.I.P.
[Normal voice]
And I couldn't go.
But then I realized
that she had done a drawing --
in jail? -- of the "SNL" sketch.
-She did a drawing of you
in the sketch.
-In the sketch. In ICE, I guess?
ICE. She's in ICE.
-Yeah.
-I should get that right.
She's not in jail.
Yeah, so she did the drawing,
and then I had to have it.
And I was consulting friends,
and they were like,
"Don't buy it.
Don't give her your address."
And so I gave her my address
and my Social Security number.
And $250 later...
-You actually have
a piece of art from her.
-Ay-ohh!
-And you brought it here
tonight.
-Yes. Look at that, guys.
-I actually --
-I mean...
-I actually love it.
-Yeah.
-And look. "SNL" up there.
-[as Delvey] "SNL.
Run it -- Run it on my card.
Run it again!"
-I mean, come on.
-Yeah.
-Isn't that wild?
-Yes.
-By the way, can I look
at your -- at your nail?
-Oh, yes.
This is "very exclusive for...
-Can we zoom in on this? I don't
know what camera can zoom.
--...for Jimmy Fallon."
-Isn't that wild?
-"Nail art."
-How did you get that?
That "Tonight Show with
Jimmy Fallon" nail art?
-You know, my friend did it.
Yeah, she does --
she does little nail art.
"So I don't look poor."
[Normal voice]
I have to stop doing that.
-No, that's alright. Yeah.
You're always
very fashion-forward, and I know
you're getting invited
to all these fashion shows.
And you look great in these.
-Thank you.
-Do you like
going to fashion shows?
-I love it, I love it.
I love it. I do.
-You really do?
-I do.
I -- It's stressful,
I didn't realize.
Like, well, first of all,
I'm wearing Tom Ford.
-Hey!
-Yeah, hey.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
And this summer I
was invited to "Vogue."
-Chloe, come on...
-Yeah. "Vogue."
And I didn't realize
you have to be on time for that.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about?
-Well, I -- like --
First of all,
a fashion show
is about five minutes
because they just walk in
the clothes and then it's done.
It's not like a play.
-Yeah, if it's five minutes.
-If it's five minutes.
-Yeah.
-You've been --
You know. You know.
-Are you kidding me?
-Fashion god over here.
-Please.
-So, I thought it started
at 7:30,
so I got there at 7:32.
And everyone was seated,
and it was, like,
me and Kanye West like...
"Oh, sorry. Sorry..."
-"Excuse me."
-Yes.
And so I completely
freaked out about it.
So, then I was invited
to "Tom Ford. Ver--"
I need to stop.
"Very exclusive, very V.I.P."
-Yeah, very V.I.P.
-And I was panicked
about being late.
And so I got to Tom Ford
an hour and 15 minutes early.
And they were like, "Oh, well,
you're the only one here."
-Because it's not
for an hour and a half.
-Not for an hour and a half.
And so I was like,
"Well, what do I do?"
So I hid in the bathroom.
-Uh-huh.
-And then ended up being, like,
the model for the photographer,
like, to test their lighting.
-Yeah.
-I think it was kind of good
because it turned out
you got some good photos
from it.
We got one.
Look at how good you look.
-No one is there.
-There's no other human being
besides you
at this fashion show.
-Not a person is there. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"SNL" this Saturday.
Miles Teller, Kendrick Lamar.
Miles Teller is a stud.
He was here last night.
-"Stud"?
-Yeah.
People went nuts for him.
And you said -- Yeah, you go,
"He does remind me of someone."
-Yes. I --
run with me on this --
think he looks a little bit like
my puppy.
-Yeah.
And so your puppy's name is?
-My dog is named Peach.
A lot of people have said
he's hot for a dog.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-This is him
when he was very young.
But do you see, like --
You see a little bit of that?
[ Laughter ]
That eyebrows -- The eyebrows
are doing the same thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-[ Laughs ] That's pretty good.
I -- I kind of see that.
But then --
-Like, the mouth.
-Yeah.
-The brows.
-You've got the brows.
-Yeah, the cute little nose.
-But -- But then you say
he also looks like Nick Jonas.
-Yes, yes.
So, then he got older and --
and, you know,
got into his hotter phase.
Not that Nick Jonas
is hotter than Miles.
Everyone's hot. My dog is hot.
-We understand.
No one's hotter than anyone.
-Okay, now -- Yes.
Look at this.
-Here's your dog
looking like Nick Jonas.
-Right?
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, I got
a Hawaiian shirt for my dog.
-Yeah, of course.
And then you said,
"Well, I think I found out
who he exactly looks like."
-Yeah, this was --
Alex Moffat was like,
"Has anyone told you that Peach
looks a lot like Colin Farrell?"
Wait for it.
[ Drum roll ]
-That's exactly it.
That's who it is.
That's who he is.
That's who it is right there.
-Yeah, it's the brows.
-Crush it this weekend.
We're rooting for you.
-Thank you.
-And we love you.
Thank you
for coming by the show.
Chloe Fineman, everybody.
-Thanks, guys.
-Catch the season premiere
of "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend
with host Miles Teller,
musical guest Kendrick Lamar.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Arctic Monkeys.
Stick around. Tom Ford!